How do you deal with a possible pandas case? My nephew is having issues. So pandas for those
who don't know, pandas and pandas is, pandas and pandas is basically inflammation in the brain.
Pandas is caused from strep, but they're finding so when it was first discovered as a strep
infection can cause damage to neural tissue, caused microglial priming and severe
emotional breakdown of that person. It was typically in children
and it was from strep. So it was basically an untreated strep that went to the brain,
caused neural inflammation, neural damage, many times neural antibody production,
and severe emotional changes. So a pandas case would be a normal, healthy, happy,
seven-year-old child that maybe came down with an infection and then literally two days later
was this completely different person. That's typically what a parent would explain. This is not
my child, somebody kidnapped him overnight and replaced him with a different child. They're defiant,
they're angry, they're begging their head against them. What has happened to them? Autism,
what is going on? That's what pandas is. It can be, no, they're fighting, it can be not just strep
related. That's what pandas is. So it can be not in just a child, it can be an adult too. So
there can be multiple different causes from mycotoxins to mycoplasma, different bacterial infections,
different viral infections, post-concussive disorders. So more and more data is coming out on this.
Treatment can be of strep is still present, can be antibiotic therapy,
to decrease inflammation. So everything that I've had on a video that I created a few years ago,
that was more specific to microglial primate and neural antibody production. And if you go to
the website, and I mentioned this multiple holistic health hours, if you go to our website,
search neural inflammation, neural inflammation, you'll see a video that I created a neural
information in microglial primate that talks about decreasing brain inflammation. So those are the
things that you would look at, but you do want to do some discovery and some labs to see exactly
what's going on. You have to deal with diet because diet, you got gluten and dairy which are
gliato, gliato, morphine receptors in the gut, in the brain, and case you'll morphine receptors
in the gut in the brain. It's going to cause direct inflammation of the brain if you look at
from an autoimmune perspective, you have to look at other triggers that be causing
changes in mood and changes in behavior, dealing with, if it is,
bico toxins dealing with that, if it's heavy metals dealing with that, those would be detoxification,
if it's like a bicoplasma dealing with that, that'd be usually like the right for other
anti-infectious agents. So they're complex cases and that you could see changes in
turnarounds in these people and people get their child back. So, but not things to say,
likely neural inflammation is real, that speaks to that last question too when there's just
when there's changes in behavior, when you talk about repeating words, anxiety, emotional meltdowns,
those are all what are called upper motor neuron issues, meaning those are brain issues.
So, you have to deal with sources and causes of brain inflammation. So, look at that video,
neural inflammation, go to our website, search for that, go to our YouTube search for neural
inflammation under our YouTube channel or our video channel. As you'll see, it's about a 30 minute
video on microglial private, I think that will be well worth your time to go through that.
I don't want to watch that. Make an appointment with me who we could talk about some tests that we'd
want to talk about as well.